I've been a fan of joints for a long
time you know since he did The Skeptical
environmentalist
yeah Bjorn runs the Copenhagen consensus
that brings a Nobel laureate economist
together every year or the two years
yeah and they look at the if the chief
issues facing the world and and decide
and try and prioritize this year the
question was you know if you had seventy
five billion dollars how would you spend
it and not exactly the way al gore would
but I don't want to give away why don't
you just start out by talking to us and
then yeah sure
thanks and thanks a lot both John and
everyone for inviting me here the the
talk really is about why is it that the
sexy ideas that we talk about very often
they're not the smartest ones and why is
it we don't talk about the smartest ones
and I'd like to take a starting point
with something that's just about to
happen I don't know how many of you have
heard it and and in some ways I think
we'll find that that's actually a good
thing but the UN is gonna run its its
next global environment summit and Rio
and one and a half weeks how many know
of that okay so some have heard of it
but but it's a it's a follow-up is
20-year anniversary of Rio the first one
in 1992 where bush senior went down and
we all went down and it was partly where
where Kyoto was born and a lot of other
treaties and of course that was actually
the 20th anniversary of Stockholm back
in 1972 when we started thinking about
environment and I think there's some
interesting points to be made then one
of my main issues is really how we have
moved from what was obviously good ideas
to what is perhaps not so obviously a
good ideas or perhaps even bad ideas the
UN is going to try and sell us the idea
that we need to move to a green economy
because that's the way to move forward
and you know you've got to wonder a
little bit is a really a good idea to
buy stuff that's not quite as good but
you have to pay more for it is that the
way to move forward the economy
but there's some there's a good
sentiment in this sense that we want to
be green and obviously we want to do
good for the environment the problem I
have with going down to Rio this time is
that apparently the biggest issue is
about dealing with global warming it's
about cutting back on carbon dioxide
well let's just run that by ourselves
for a second here if we look at how many
people die from global warming if we
look at all the deaths from heat waves
from floods from hurricanes and from oh
god I'm forgetting one more but no not
coal smoke because that would actually
not that would not be sort of the UN
kind of way to think about this but but
but the but the idea here is to say how
many people actually die from this it
turns out 0.06 percent of all deaths in
the developing world that's that's not
an unsubstantial number people and we
certainly want to look at that what are
the biggest environmental problems in
the world right now no it's not global
warming it's simple air pollution and
water pollution water pollution kills
about 3 million people each year we're
about six point six point eight percent
of all deaths six point eight percent
that's about a hundred times more than
what global warming even if we take this
very inclusive version of it and how
many people die from air pollution well
it's about the same number about two
million people die from indoor air
pollution most people like what indoor
air Polly we totally forgotten what it's
like to be in most of the world most of
the time that you cook and keep warm by
using dirty old fuels dumb or cardboard
or whatever you can lay your hands on
that's especially women and kids that
are going to die in that and then about
a million people die of outdoor air
pollution so six million people are
about two hundred and ten times as many
as even by this very inclusive way of
looking global warming die from very
simple very old-fashioned but unsexy
environmental problem why on earth are
we going down to Rio and saying oh we
want to be all good and nice and sweet
and spend huge amounts of money fixing a
problem fairly inefficiently that only
kills
200 intense of how much good we good
have done elsewhere and that's really
the I think the the the the access code
to the stuff that I try to do mainly to
try us to think about where can we get a
lot of purchase on our money instead of
where we can just do a little bit Rio is
one example global warming is obviously
a generally good example of how we we
worry about somebody mentioned malaria
and and it's a good example if you read
pretty much anything about malaria today
it's about malaria and global warming
yes global warming probably because it
increases temperature it probably
increases the extent where you would
have malaria to be endemic where you the
mosquitoes can survive
we're actually estimating by the end of
the century we'll probably have about
three percent more malaria because of
global warming but of course there's a
hundred percent of malaria right now
people die from malaria not because of
global warming but because they're poor
and the the the thing that blows my mind
is that we talk about malaria as a
global warming thing because it makes it
sexy but the unsexy people who die from
from from malaria just happened to be
orders of magnitude bigger or to put it
differently because remember if we
actually tried to do something about
global warming even if we did it fairly
efficiently we could probably for about
a hundred and and eighty billion dollars
a year we could probably save a couple
hundred people from dying from malaria
each year throughout the century oh
that's that's not it trivial but but it
just strikes me as bizarre that we know
we can pretty much eradicate malaria for
about three billion dollars a year so to
put it differently for every time
climate change policies could save one
person from dying from malaria the same
amount of money spent on malaria
policies could save 36,000 people from
dying from malaria so again my point is
why is it we're so focused on the one
sexy death instead of the unsexy 36,000
deaths and what I'd like to say is that
we try to make that sexy again that we
try to be smart isn't that supposed to
be sexy I don't know so at the end of
the day this is not just within climate
change when we've done a few other
with the Copenhagen consensus in them we
can start you can start quizzing me but
but we did a whole consensus just on HIV
HIV obviously is a big disease
especially in sub-saharan Africa it's
dramatically made made average lifespans
decline it's cost communities huge
amounts of money there's some very
different ways to try to tackle HIV one
is prevention basically get condoms out
and other one is focusing on medical
solutions like a vaccine or or maybe a
circumcision and a third one is to get
people drugs now obviously you want to
get people drugs we actually have an
territorial so help people it just so
happens that they're incredibly
expensive even though that the price has
gone down dramatically they're much much
more expensive than most of the other
solutions that we have but those are the
solutions that are both easy and sexy in
the public sphere here's the sake person
we're gonna help him or her instead of
focusing on the much less sexy ones that
are prevention or the ones that focus on
long-term investment for instance in in
research and on an HIV vaccine it's not
nearly as fun but if it actually does a
lot more and again what one of the
things that we tried to show was the
investment if you spend a dollar on on
treatment you probably do two to three
dollars worth of good that's good that's
definitely better than some of the stuff
we do with climate but if you spin it on
an HIV vaccine you would probably do
about twenty dollars worth of good and
if you focus on on prevention you can
probably do in the order ten to twenty
again why is that we focus on the wrong
things and that's one of the things I I
would love us to to talk more about and
so fundamentally what I try to do is to
get us off this feeling good you know
doing stuff that makes us all feel good
you know we put up a lot of wind
turbines in Denmark they don't actually
do very much but it makes us feel really
good I would like us to do stuff that
actually works the thing that blows my
mind is that we spend so much money on
feeling good when I'm pretty sure
our kids and grandkids are not gonna
laud us for how beautifully we spoke but
whether we actually fix them it's always
amazed me that something like climate
change it's not really that sexy of
topic itself wind turbines you know
energy stuff recycling garbage I mean
the fact that people are obsessed with
garbage is an amazing thing to me I mean
what is it about that that gives it this
emotional sort of religious I mean it is
it religion is it I mean what is it that
makes that it makes people feel good
doing that stuff as opposed to something
practical well I think if I could just
take the garbage example I that's
another thing that blows my mind and and
I think yours too is it what is it that
people recycle is recycling a good idea
yes sometimes it is remember for
instance copper we've recycled couple
for the whole century because it's a
smart idea cost a lot of money to get
out of ground we have a lot of stuff
that actually lies around especially if
we tear down buildings of course you're
recycling
we've recycle about the same proportion
all the way through the century but
that's not what we talk about when we
talk about recycling that's smart
no it's about recycling paper and glass
oh wait a minute
we worried that we run out of trees or
of sands and is a big problem it's not a
renewable resource actually and I think
I know a place where there's so
fundamentally it's not the right things
we worry about but it makes us feel good
again it makes us and I talk to a lot of
people and I my senses it really makes
them feel like they're part of the
solution what did is it guilt do you
think I mean someone said to me after I
read about recycle in it and one of the
best explanations I heard for later was
someone said that people like to think
of themselves there were really
spiritual beings we don't need all this
all this stuff you know that we're
really above all that and that seeing
all the garbage in their house
it's like lipstick on the collar of our
love affair with stuff and that's why
you can't you just want to do something
with it to expiate the guilt and
therefore and we said so I didn't really
buy that stuff I'm just recycling it I
don't really need that and and
to me that's been an explanation for you
know why this obsession with recycling
and how much of that is going on with
you know climate stuff that I can't burn
this fuel I can't do that I'm I just
feel so guilty about using things that I
have to somehow make up for it is that I
mean you deal with greens all the time
what do you know III think it might very
well be the case I again I try to bring
in a rational argument so I have a very
very hard time exactly understanding but
I think it's very much the sense of it
has a personal it's a personalized
affect I actually think that's one of
the reasons why it's really hard to do
something about climate even if you do
badly as a lot of my opponents would
like to do it's very hard to convince
people because it's not sexy to know oh
I buy electricity that comes from winter
buy I mean it looks the same the lights
the same kind of thing so that's why I
think the thing that blew my mind when
when when we were talking a lot about
climate was I don't know if you saw Al
Gore was in in with Oprah and they both
went to Home Depot global warming and it
looks great I don't think they go there
very often they were just buying these
compact fluorescent light bulbs the
light energy-saving light bulbs and then
they were like hey we still solve global
warming and that makes you feel good
because that you can actually do or you
can buy a hybrid and then you feel like
oh I've really done something and
there's nothing wrong mean we should be
doing those kinds of things but it's not
what's gonna fix global warming so we've
stuck with these small solutions these
putting up solar panels on your rooftop
Germany has put up the most solar panels
in the world per capita if you guys have
ever been to Germany you know that's a
weird place to start is it I saw there
as a result is it kind of an eyesore all
these things on the roof I think so but
as some people think they're very
beautiful they put them up on a third of
all the medieval cathedrals you're like
what of all the places you know anyway
but but but the but the fact is they've
actually spent a hundred and thirty
billion dollars in subsidies and some
subsidies for for an energy that's worth
about twenty twelve billion dollars and
and the net effect of all that extra
money there
spent is to postpone global warming by
the end of the century by 23 hours but
when you tell people that they're sort
of like oh yeah we didn't think of that
because you just feel like see I can't I
can look up on my rooftop and see how
good I am
well it's like a cathedral in that sense
they do practical value the cathedrals
either fun fun Amelie I think it's about
realizing and and this is also one of
the things we keep saying in code making
consensus wayney when you make all this
sort of rational analysis it's very very
hard to engage people who are
fundamentally on this and how do you do
this that because you have been been
fighting this fight now for so long I
really admire your persistence at it how
do you try to get through the lid to
this sort of fundamental emotional side
I remember when Greg Easterbrook didn't
you know did his book a moment on the
earth and Greg was so he really tried to
come down hard and you do a well to his
hard talking to the other side talking
to green language and he was just kind
of terrorized at bookstores and he just
couldn't believe the the religious furor
on the other side now you've done this
for for so many years now how do you try
to get that across to them well I think
this there's two things to it one is to
recognize that everyone in this
conversation I think want to do good so
instead of trying to make it at them us
a discussion it's about all of us trying
to do the best thing you can and and so
when you say this 23 hours obviously the
the first reaction is no no that can't
be true but then when you you know you
take them through the calculations
they're so little
hmm because I actually want it to leave
something good for my kids and grandkids
and then you can start getting into this
sort of conversation and then if you can
also give them alternatives where you
say well instead of putting up this
incredibly inefficient solar panel
that's just not really going to do
anything by the way one of the things
that happen and we've seen this in
Germany but also happens elsewhere is
you can't subsidize your way out of this
because suddenly as soon as it actually
gets popular you can't afford it that's
it's it's destined to forever be a
boutique little niche kind of thing and
that those kinds of arguments really get
them because they realized oh that's
right my solution is actually not ever
gonna work
and then you pull them in and say look
there are other solutions innovation
that's what solved pretty much all
problems do you guys remember it back in
1970 when we thought everybody was gonna
you know basically run out of food and
not have anymore
this solution was not to ask you know we
thought India was pretty much done for
the solution obviously was not to say to
everyone could you please eat a little
less that's not gonna work but what we
was the solution was come up with smart
new varieties of you of foodstuff a
bracer of wheat that actually produces a
lot more and of course in the same way
the solution is not to tell everyone
could you please use less energy it's
about saying can you eventually use a
lot of energy but without emitting the
co2 and that's about innovation that's
much cheaper it's much more effective
and it's actually something that we can
get everybody to agree on because we'd
all love to have green energy those
incredibly cheap yeah so let's focus on
innovation and the beautiful beauty of
that is you can actually come up to
people who are really really worried and
say why don't we do that instead and
they'll typically say oh we should
definitely do that and a lot of other
stupid things but yeah there you go so
spend a hundred billion for solar panels
that research and study yes yes I mean
that would actually make a huge
difference in my mean the simple point
here is to say as long as solar panels
and wind turbines and all the other
stuff there's much more expensive than
fossil fuels you never can get people to
switch but if it was cheaper we'd be
done everyone would buy them we wouldn't
have to have a Kyoto Protocol or
anything else that's the problem though
I mean there wouldn't be conferences to
go to say I actually don't think most
big well I don't know for all of them
but I think a lot of them would like to
not have to go to these conferences
actually have a solution so so at the
end of the day it's about appealing to
where you can do a lot of smart things
and then of course there's the other
thing that geoengineering
looking at at least having an insurance
policy a lot of people talk about global
warming and cutting back on co2 as an
insurance policy because what if
something really bad happened but the
truth of course is it's not an insurance
policy to cut down because an insurance
policy makes sure that you get your
money back if for instance your house
burns down there's nobody to give you
the money back if it burns down what you
can do is to make sure that you have
technology that potentially could avoid
a dramatic tipping point now I had heard
rumors that the to engineering and doing
this climate engineering that it was
being considered as one of the top
priorities is here Copenhagen is that
right now it ended up being 12 on the
list I guess yes yes but it but it had a
very very good benefit cost ratio I mean
the the academics themselves said but
this this requires a lot of
consideration of exactly how damaging do
you think it is but fundamentally we
have good reason to believe that if you
could implement and if it works that is
that we could basically seal off a
little bit of the sunlight coming into
the planet either by putting up soft
particulate in the stratosphere that's
what volcanoes do or make clouds a
little wider we could probably avoid all
of global warming impacts for this
century for about in the order of five
to ten billion dollars now remember
that's about a thousand to ten thousand
times cheaper than what anyone else is
talking about so it might be worth
looking at now we don't know whether it
works I find it amusing that the you
know the the only the only study that's
ever been done was done by National
Geographic because they needed something
for show really they actually they they
built one of these cloud whitening
machines and you're like if this is one
of the biggest problems with humanity
maybe we want somebody else to do a
slightly better study than now that I
know they're men pretty programs but you
don't want that to be sort of where we
run out of policy business but at the
end of the day this just simply shows us
that there's much smarter much cheaper
ways to actually engage with the problem
and that of course also leaves a lot of
other funds to open up to deal with
these very basic things that we worry
about with air pollution water pollution
and all the other problems remember the
biggest environmental problem the world
is not air pollution of water pollution
it's poverty yeah yeah about a quarter
of all deaths in the world about fifteen
billion is are million people each year
about a Florida each year die from
easily curable infectious diseases and
that's because you're poor and of course
if you're poor you'll raise a force to
two
even to do slash-and-burn agriculture
for to feed your kids and likewise
you're not gonna care about the
environment in 100 years if if your kids
are hungry tonight
yeah that's now you've got a libertarian
audience here and so the question when
you talk about helping poor people is if
for instance it at the top of the list
this year for its some very unsexy
things but really worthwhile courses the
number one was bun the the most
cost-effective way to spend seventy five
billion dollars to help the most people
was bundle micronutrient interventions
expanding subsidy for malaria was number
two then child in child vaccines
deworming of school children now these
are all wonderful ideas to do these
things but now the question is how much
can we we want to feel good helping
people in saving lives really but but
how much good can we really do for these
countries and I mean how much good is
international aid really do yeah and and
that's a huge and and and very very
disputed discussion I don't think
there's a simple answer to because it
really depends on what we do some of the
things we do are incredibly good and
some of the things we do are incredibly
bad what we try to focus on is there are
some things that we know really work
very very simply and let me just give
you an example of the top thing because
I I think we haven't really realized how
incredibly good nutrition can be back in
the late 1960s early 70s there was a big
study in Guatemala where they did a
randomized control study where they gave
some cities their villages it was
adequate nutrition and the others they
didn't I don't know how they got that
past the ethics committee bit but but
the beauty of that is that we now 40
years later it's just published last
year can follow these guys they're now
and they're in their 40s and we can see
not only did it mean dramatically reduce
stunting basically that they didn't you
know grow to be incredibly low and and
and and and somewhat undeveloped but
they actually both got better
development mentally and physically they
stayed longer in school they learned a
lot more for every year they were in
school but and this is the crucial point
now we know that they are almost twice
as well-paid as the people who weren't
well fed basically you become a lot more
productive I mean it's it's not really
all that surprising when you think about
it but we've never really considered
that nutrition could be such an
important way it's a way to solve
undernutrition and stunting it's a way
to solve education and it's really the
best way that we know how to deal with
education but it's also a way to get
people rich and so that we can actually
do fairly well all right well I mean
there's there's a number of different
things it's it involves making sure that
you get micronutrients you get that in
the vaccine day so that we already have
so you're basically a piggybacking on it
you get public information that we have
fairly well demonstrated that you if you
teach mothers this is incredibly
important to feed their kids well and
then in in schools but on schools these
these are from zero to two years so
they're not yet in school but you get
them to go to schools like every half
year and you give them a special taste
and give them some extra nutrition that
will stay with them for quite a while
it's not you know ideal but it's the
best we can do given the circumstances
again is some of this money gonna be why
said yes but because it's in a
dramatically good investment and and the
reason why came out on top is probably
the benefit is for every dollar spent
somewhere between 60 and 100 dollars
back home so you know we can afford to
lose 50 dollars and still do very very
good in the in the world so the trick
here is to realize two things that we
can actually do some things that will
make immense amounts of benefits but the
other thing of course is to remember
that there are some structural things we
need to do and that's that's that's my
other gripe and again it comes down to
the sexy own sexy why is that everyone
talks about Kyoto that's just one city
where we have one treaty there's an
other city which we've totally dropped
off Doha the idea of having more free
trade in the world global warming
basically is going to harm the third
world and basically in a hundred years
so it's not really a big threat for
developed countries and it's not our
threat now but it will be a threat in
the long-term future and especially to
the developing world it turns out that
free trade has much the same character
fix free trade if we manage to get a
successful Doha round according to the
World Bank models
we'd probably be about 125 billion
dollars richer and the world that's nice
most of it actually go to the rich world
because we're best poised to to take the
advantage of it but it's not very much
but what it would do is it would start
meaning that we would grow faster
because you didn't have to reinvent the
the wheel all the time you'd actually be
able to buy it from someone else so
you'd get faster growth and so the
dynamic models from the World Bank
estimate the towards the end of the
century we would on average per year be
about five thousand billion dollars
richer most three three quarters to
fourth fifth would go to the developing
world
so we're basically talking about if we
don't do something about global warming
we will mainly harm the third world in a
hundred years but if we don't do
something about don't have will mainly
harm the developing world in a hundred
years and the curious fact is that Doha
would be about ten times better than any
kind of climate legislation we could
ever make for helping the third world
for helping the third world and of
course any realistic climate policy
would be on the order of a hundred to a
thousand times less good than a success
and you make any progress when you when
you talk about something like that at
colleges and the Occupy Wall Street
trying to tell them about free trade how
does one no no it's it's a difficult
argument I think at the end of the day
you cannot if you want to move from
something that's sexy sexy is
immediately obvious and people will
latch on to it unsexy is not yeah I'm
almost by definition and so what you
have to say is this is not about getting
it right it's not about you're moving
everyone to that oh now we're smart now
we're you know fully informed it's just
about saying let's try to not get it
quite as badly wrong and that that's
what I try to do and I I think in that
way you can actually succeed you can get
people to real whoo that's right and
again because you focus on people
actually want to do good they actually
want to leave a better planet for their
kids and grandkids and so if you start
talking about well what you're doing
right now is not working yeah
the
I think when I when I talk to greens the
the best example is really to say we've
been talking about global warming for
twenty years we've been trying Kyoto for
20 years so it's not entirely true but
that sort of approach for 20 years it's
not worked for 20 years it's actually
failed for 20 years do you really want
to be the guy who said let's keep doing
this for another decade yeah
or should we try to do smarter things so
if you engage people in that way I think
you can actually get them to to listen
and to certain extent changed their
minds and their policies I think that's
a great note to end on